first of all congrats on the movie i
want to start with that but if someone
has actually never seen anything that
you've done before what is the first
thing they should watch and why the gray
man the grey man obviously because it's
the biggest action movie of the year
i was wondering if there's gonna be
something pulled out of the of the
resume but that's fine pulled out of the
abyss
the abyss of the past
each job so fresh it's like nothing's
ever happened before uh this movie has
what i will call a f ton of action and
it does feel like uh ryan gosling fights
everyone but you guys were you a little
bit upset that you were like two of the
only people that didn't fight him in the
movie i mean i kind of fight him a
little bit tiny little bit
um
we we
we're not on the same page let's put it
that way
we verbally fight him yeah i think that
we do the mental scar scarring mental
scarring and mental sparring mental
scarring i was going for that's fine um
no i think i'm i have no resentment for
playing puppet master i think that
there's something very fun about setting
the troglodytes out to do the grunt work
and then we kind of hang out in the
office and orchestrate the chaos
uh you know what it's like to make
action sequences though especially after
matrix and you know what goes into those
things so it is maybe it's a little good
to not have to have done like uh you
know month-long
we were on set and i was watching the
actors go in and out of the training
room
deobia opera who i did game of thrones
with years ago is in this film and he
was training four months for a 10 minute
sequence
and uh yeah i did not envy him at all i
was like oh pain or your back
oh no baby okay have fun
uh i love learning about like the behind
the scenes of the making of films and tv
shows so for soon to be fans of this
movie what do you think might surprise
them to learn about the making of the
film we shot it in long beach we shot an
awful lot of it in a hangar in long
beach the amount of movie magic that
goes on in this film is extraordinary um
mostly because we shot so much in the
middle of the pandemics so there's a lot
of kind of ad hoc
building of imaginary environments um we
barely got to hang out between takes
because we had to hang out like separate
bubble tents um and jess would just like
kind of pass me notes under the floor
saying hey can we be friends and i'd
send back a little note full of hearts
saying no
we kind of just
carried on in that vein yeah i know that
it was shot in long beach but i'm going
to say that the production design of the
sets you would never know not in a
million years no it looks incredible and
i think that's one of the best things
about the standards of arusa brothers
movie like it looks
so incredible they're kind of at the top
of their game and then just topping
their own game beyond that and being a
part of that is just thrilling
there's a lot in this movie to like rave
about but is there one maybe one or two
things that you really are looking
forward for people to see
julia butters i think she's the heart
and soul of the film i really she's so
talented and has a huge career ahead of
her so i'm excited she's an honest to
goodness inspiration absolutely it's
quite so professional she was probably
the most professional out of all of us
they're also close second danush danush
was amazing the grace and style and
badassery of that man in this film is
something to behold and i think that's
going to be a bit of a
a thunderbolt for folks he has very
quiet power and i want that power he's
actually fantastic in the film yeah like
i really was like oh wait oh oh okay you
know what i mean if batman was like
twice as badass he might get halfway to
where denish gets to in this movie
that is a quote
you